et puis le maire de laval le marc demers
a décidé de marquer le coup pour ses 100
premiers jours à la tête de la ville
avec deux mesures qui selon lui vont
contribuer à rétablir l'ordre
il lance notamment une enquête publique
sur l'un des projets les plus
controversés des dernières années à
laval les fameuses tours du commodore
francis labbé
dès le départ le projet a fait grand
bruit des tours à condos de luxe de 28
et 30 étages situé au bord de la rivière
des prairies les citoyens du quartier
s'y sont opposés les deux tours
commodore de 28 et 30 étages sont
complètement disproportionnées ils vont
à l'encontre même des des balises du
plan particulier d'urbanisme qui
demandent des espaces verts riverains
l'accès aux berges
le maire de laval marc demers a entendu
les opposants je vous annonce le
déclenchement d'une enquête
administrative au sujet du projet et
mobilier le commodore selon le maire
demers des modifications tardive au
règlement par l'ancienne administration
ont eu pour effet de soustraire ce
projet à un référendum des quartiers ces
allégations sont graves
nous allons au fond des choses
le commodore ce que ça vous dit quelque
chose effectivement les tours du
commodore ont beaucoup fait parler
d'elle depuis un an devant la commission
charbonneau en mai dernier l'ex
directeur adjoint de laval a précisé que
l'ancienne administration insistait pour
que le projet aille de l'avant
on me mentionnait qu'elle douchy était
présenté dans une structure une façon
acceptable
puis en pleine campagne électorale
municipale dans une conversation
enregistrée à son insu
l'ex maire gilles vaillancourt a
reproché à la candidate à la mairie
claire lebel de s'être opposé au projet
l'union nous avons pu rejoindre l'un des
deux promoteurs à l'origine du projet le
groupe aldo construction car refusé de
nous accorder une entrevue sur le sujet
il affirme malgré tout que le projet
respecte ray selon lui les
réglementations en vigueur et il attend
les conclusions de l enquête
les citoyens veulent que les abus et les
jeux de coulisses cesse le maire demers
ne s'est pas arrêté là
il a annoncé qu'il retenait la prime de
départ attribuée à pierre desroches
l'ex pdg de laval technopole le maire de
laval veut faire la lumière sur cet
autre contrat signé par l'administration
vaillancourt ici francis labbé à laval